six years ago this week a Scientologist
tried to recruit me to Scientology I
told the story six years ago it's a
great story and I'll retell it quickly
my mom was away on vacation and she had
asked me to check in on the handyman who
was doing some repair work at her house
he was going to be painting and using
products that she didn't want to be
around until they were dried or cured or
whatever so the idea was he'll do the
work while she's gone and I go over
there and this guy was driving around
town with a sticker on his work van
which said rush was right rush limbaugh
was right so I thought he was just
generally a right-winger and probably
like a conservative Christian type and
he says to me hey David have you ever
heard about l ron Hubbard and I said to
him assuming that this guy was a
right-wing Christian who wanted to
ridicule l ron Hubbard with me I said
yeah isn't that the science-fiction
writer who made up a religion
Scientology and he says oh no you know
it's funny you mention that a lot of
people think that but actually L ron
Hubbard is an amazing man and I've been
able to do miracles as a result of what
he's taught and you know you're into
business and he is the best business
teacher at the time I was thinking
you're driving around in a completely
dilapidated work van doing to be quite
frank mediocre work that he was never
rehired to do by my mom also in part
because of the Scientology recruitment
of course so it didn't really make sense
to me but he insisted he said you know I
actually I sell the books and I I sold a
woman a book in the next town over and
she was just amazed by it and she was
able to do miracles as a result of what
what I learned and at this point I said
I do not want to be branded a
suppressive person by this guy and I
just played dumb like I really didn't
know that much about and I said oh okay
yeah I'll think about that I'll let you
know if I'm interested in buying a book
a week later I went to do another check
in on him and there was a letter in my
mom's mailbox and you know how though if
you want the mail person to take a
letter you put it vertically and I saw
that there was a letter sticking out and
I open it and it's
from this guy to the Church of
Scientology some kind of a donation or
whatever sending in his money long story
short I was able to avoid recruitment
and I as far as I know I was able to
avoid being branded as a suppressive
person and I told my mom about it she
was horrified never hired this guy again
yes I would have probably lost my cool
if someone were proselytizing while
under my employ yeah in my home right
yeah I don't know how I would keep my
temper any situation like that I only
played it cool because first of all this
guy was huge I mean he must have been
300 pounds in six six he was like a
lumberjack and so physically I didn't
want him to get get angry with me
because of what that might mean and you
know my mom was out of the country and I
was sort of responsible for the for this
guy and monitoring him it just didn't
make sense to anger this guy but yes he
was not hired again have not even run
into him since ever again and that's
good news for everybody that's for sure
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s